là dès qu'ils amènent en voulez vous
chanter la chanson non à l'origine donc
3 2 et quand elle m'a dit la grande aura
mais son bracelet
on s'est aimés d'accolades
m
je m'adresse à la production est ce
qu'il pourrait y avoir un contrôle de ce
qui va être fait au pas sur le plateau
arrêtons les initiatives personnelles
sans effet ça ne paie jamais croyez moi
voici la liste à mesdames et messieurs
des choses que jean michel mr a envie de
faire chanter parrot c'est une
exclusivité malal rose
on y va merci à prendre 23 verges thème
en slip parterre boire de la vodka et
fait chaud chez ikea
les gros décolleté les photographier et
ensuite les matins
écrire une liste des boîtes échangistes
et finir la nuit pourrait aller
travailler bague et tous les invités
prendre son numéro et se prend un râteau
[Applaudissements]
régulièrement les gens étaient chez vous
en raconter une très courte mais vrai
l'émission succès que je présentais
l'époque en direct je ne dirai pas le
nom de la star évidemment la star
s'assoit à côté de nous on me fait
antennes dans quinze secondes on est en
direct
elle a un verre transparent et on me dit
à l'oreillette il faut pas laisser lever
arrange le je vais pour le ranger comme
chez soi parce que j'ai la gorge et
imprécises est-ce que je peux le bois
même sans problème basique je le prends
au cul sec
c'est de la vodka je ne sais pas hélas
générique c'est moi j'ai les yeux comme
ça
isabelle s'il vous plaît cette idole
j'ai un toit sans course sympa et
marathon des bouquets pas du tout la
réunion a vu durée supérieure parce que
race que lille h tout comme ça c'est
très très long il paraît comme ça jean
michel avec une femme si vous la draguer
en lui parlant comme ça ça donnerait
quoi
c'est combien obama
[Applaudissements]
et non
attendez on a la gentillesse de proposer
de l'argent mais aussi